in the decades since its release 1997's
starship troopers has become a cult
classic
many of the actors from this sci-fi
favorite have never stopped working so
let's see what they've been up to since
nuking those bugs
here's what the cast of starship
troopers is doing today
casper van deen got the role of a
lifetime when he was cast as the lead in
starship troopers
he played johnny rico a young man who
had a troubled start to his life in the
infantry
however he soon worked his way up to
lieutenant with natural talent and a
very simple military strategy
[Music]
shortly after the film came out van dien
found himself with another prominent
role
this time he was acting alongside johnny
depp in sleepy hollow
since the late 90s van deen has appeared
in dozens of films on the big and small
screen but he hasn't forgotten his roots
he returned to the part of rico for
starship troopers 3 marauder
and he provided the voice for the same
character in the cg animated film
starship troopers trader of mars in
recent years van dien has appeared on
television
in shark tapas vs whale wolf and hawaii
5-0
in 2019 he returned to theaters in the
sci-fi
action adventure elita battle angel the
james cameron produced project may have
been a relatively rare big screen
appearance for van dien
but he's always busy and we definitely
haven't seen the last of him
deena meyer played private dizzy flores
in starship troopers
initially she was one of rico's
classmates but she ended up as a member
of his infantry squad
dis and rico fought giant killer bugs
side by side
and eventually formed a romantic
relationship
just a few years after appearing in
starship troopers meyer joined the cast
of the short-lived tv series birds of
prey as barbara gordon
also known as oracle it was a role she
would reprise many years later
this time however it was a short
voiceover part for the flash
as part of the crisis on infinite
earth's crossover arc
in between appearances as oracle meyer
made a name for herself in the horror
genre
she played a prominent role in the saw
franchise as detective carrie
appearing in the series all the way up
until saw four other horror movies you
might have seen her in include piranha
3d
and the evil within no stranger to the
small screen
she also made an appearance in an
episode of american horror story
before she appeared in tabloids
alongside charlie sheen
denise richards played the role of
carmen evanez in starship troopers
while it was one of her first major film
roles it wouldn't be her last
not long after the movie came out she
co-starred in the successful and
notorious film
wild things and in 1999 richards was in
the james bond movie the world is not
enough
where she played a nuclear physicist
with a very memorable name
doctor jones christmas jones
and don't make any jokes i've heard them
all
i don't know any doctor jokes in 2000
richards met her future husband charlie
sheen on the set of good advice
the pair tied the knot in 2002 and they
would go on to appear together in the
2003 film scary movie 3.
after a rocky and very public
relationship richards and sheen divorced
in 2006.
through the years richards is kept
extremely busy appearing in films and tv
shows
since 2019 she's been a regular cast
member of the bold and the beautiful
and the real housewives of beverly hills
as the son of gary busey jake busey was
destined to become an actor
after many smaller roles his big break
came in 1997 when he starred in two
major sci-fi flicks
contact and starship troopers since that
time he's been working non-stop
appearing in a wide variety of tv shows
and films one of his most popular roles
came in 2014 when he landed a part in
from dusk till dawn the series
you've also likely seen him make brief
but memorable appearances in other tv
shows such as
agents of shield and stranger things
where his character morphed from
annoying to deadly
also in 2018 bucy followed in the
footsteps of his famous father
and appeared in a predator film while
michael ironside has been acting since
the 70s
many movie fans were first introduced to
him in starship troopers
he played lieutenant rajak the commander
of the bug crushing roughnecks and
johnny rico's old high school teacher
rochak was highly respected for his
combat skills
leadership qualities and keen
battlefield observations
[Music]
they sucked his brains out
since his time leading the roughnecks
ironside has portrayed an
endless array of tough guys including an
animated one
he voiced the character of darkseid on
superman the animated series
justice league and justice league
unlimited however you've still been
able to see his face on many occasions
he was the captain of the seventh fleet
in x-men first class and he's appeared
in the flash television series as louis
snart
the father of captain cold most recently
ironside had a major role as jp morgan
and the alienist
and like casper van dien he appeared in
an episode of hawaii 5.0
seth gilliam played the heroic sugar
watkins in starship troopers
a loyal member of the roughnecks who
gave his all to protect his comrades and
take out as many bugs as possible
after that role gilliam went on to star
in 17 episodes of the hit series
oz as clayton hughes it wouldn't be the
last time he would star in a prestigious
hbo series
you also likely recognize him as
sergeant ellis carver from the wire
however his most prominent role as of
late has been as gabriel stokes on the
walking dead
after being filled with regret over
those he didn't save from the zombie
outbreak
gabriel goes on to become one of rick
grimes most trusted allies in the fight
for peace
neil patrick harris was already a
recognizable star by 1997
thanks to his years playing the title
role in the hit series doogie howser md
in starship troopers however he was able
to show off a bit more of his adult
sensibilities with his portrayal of the
brilliant carl jenkins
a role which had a major impact on some
fans
your part in starship troopers truly
truly
changed my life really harris went on to
score various parts on television but he
jumped back into the mainstream when he
played himself
in the film harold and kumar go to white
castle it was his chance to let his
comedic skills take center stage
and it likely played a part in his
landing the role of barney stinson on
how i met your mother
since the final episode of that beloved
sitcom in 2014
harris hasn't slowed down in the
slightest he's portrayed a wide range of
characters on stage and film
including desi collings from the movie
gone girl also
in 2017 harris joined the world of
streaming television with his role as
count
olaf and his various incarnations in a
series of unfortunate events on netflix
i prefer long-form television to the
movies it's so much more convenient to
consume entertainment from the comfort
of your own home
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
classic movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you